yeah this is I'm happy to give this talk
it's a kind of a very different talk
from what I'm used to because I'm kind
of come more from the provable security
side then from the side of attacking
things but it was nice challenge to to
basically you know prepare this and try
to give an overview of how how to attack
hash functions in in post quantum
computer graphic schemes so probably
most of you know that hash functions are
essentially everywhere in cryptography
so whether it's digital signatures or
key establishment or for example a crypt
you know encryption public key
encryption basically all of these
important functionalities are
constructed using hash functions and
there's a number of others that that are
maybe not so present in yeah that are
not as widely used or that are more like
sub primitives of that I used to
construct the other ones and one
important question is of course whether
we can use quantum algorithms to attack
the use of hash functions in these
khodro graphic schemes this is what the
talk will be about so here's an outline
I will start by introducing hash
functions so this is kind of a mixed
audience of quantum algorithms people
and cryptography so a cryptographer so I
don't want to assume too much so I will
thoroughly introduce what a hash
function is it's security properties
then quickly talk about the so-called
random Oracle model or its quantum
variant and also give an idea of how
hash functions are actually constructed
after that I will continue by kind of
giving different meta strategies of how
to attack hash functions and
subsequently I will focus on one of them
which is attacking the use of hash
functions in cryptographic schemes for
I will introduce the these two important
and air transformations that are used in
many cryptographic schemes that that are
competing in this nist process which are
called fiat amir transformation and
Fujisaki Okamoto transformations and
then after that I will talk about
attacks or the lack thereof using
quantum algorithms let's get started so
first of all what what is the hash
function a hash function is basically
just a pair or it's just a function and
it takes arbitrary length bit strings as
an input and then it maps these to a
fixed length output and and so what you
can imagine that in practice that we
just take like some arbitrary amount of
data and we map it to some small
fingerprint or something like that and
basically the defining intuition for
security is that a hash function should
look random to somebody who has not you
know input the same string into the hash
function before there's a number of more
concrete security properties that are
informed by this intuition and they they
include the ones that I've put here but
this is not an exhaustive list so most
importantly there's one-wayness which is
the property that for a random image of
this function I cannot find a
corresponding pyramids and collision
resistance which says that I cannot find
to impose that met to the same output
and then a number of strengthening of
this like for example collapsing this
which is a property that replaces
collision resistance in the quantum
setting if if you if used hash functions
for commitments for example and a number
more basically consistent with the fact
that our that these these properties
were defined by our into following our
intuition that the function should look
like a random function a random function
at an actual random function has all
these properties
and therefore sometimes we resort to
kind of fantasy world which we call a
random or the random Oracle model where
we just pretend that the hash function
is in fact a random random function so I
want to explain a bit more what this
what this random Oracle model is about
but before that let me give an example
application of hash functions and that's
the so-called hash and sign paradigm so
if you first of all what is the digital
signature scheme so here we have two
players Alice and Bob and else wants to
send a message to Bob she would like to
ensure that this messages arrives
unaltered at Bob's and that Bob knows
that it comes from her so for this she
already earlier has generated a key pair
where she has kept the secret key secret
and to herself and the published the
public key she has published and somehow
established Bob's trust in this public
key so basically Bob trusts that this
public key belongs to Alice yes it's in
a cloud so now Alice can use the signing
functionality to sign this message
generating is a signature Sigma and send
the pair M Sigma to Bob Bob can now use
the verification function which uses the
public key only to verify that verify
that this message indeed comes from
Ellison is unaltered now assigning
signature schemes are pretty inefficient
compared to hash functions so therefore
one can use the hash and sign paradigm
by choosing an appropriate hash function
with you know large enough Co domain and
then hashing the message before signing
and this this is a very good idea
because it saves some computation
because the signing functional
functional is very computation intensive
and it should not harm security as long
as the hash function is collision
resistant in this case collision
resistance is enough and and you know
the hash function has a large enough
output
so yeah so this was just an illustrative
example of overuse of hash functions so
let's move on to a bit more information
about this quantum random Oracle model
so here we really pretend that the hash
function is a random function and the
random function is of course you know
you can you cannot efficiently specify
it so we just have to assume that
everybody has Oracle access so
input-output access to this hash
function to do this random function H
and to kind of keep at least some
connection to reality in in the case
where we are talking about quantum
attackers we need to assume that
everybody has quantum oracle access to
this function right because in reality
we're dealing with the concrete function
everybody can implement it on their
quantum computers if they have one so
which would at least allow you know
quantum evaluation of this of this
random function if we model our concrete
function as such this is the so-called
quantum random Oracle model and it was
introduced by by some people including
Christian er who's here and it just to
be a bit more concrete so this is
basically the standard implement unitary
implementation of offer for classical
function and this is basically the
functionality did that we assume
everybody in the world has has access to
for a random function H this has been
very successful because it has enabled
provable security for very efficient
schemes but you know it has a downside
because it's not the real world like we
we are pretending that it's a random
function while it's not and this is a
fact that actually allows for for
vulnerabilities in principle which I
will talk about a bit more later so now
a bit more about the construction of
hash functions so we want a hash
function this object with arbitrary
length input but there's kind of an a
bit of an unwielding object because it
it has we are supposed to basically
evaluate it on any line
strings on it on this infinite domain so
what much easier is to construct a fixed
domain a fixed length domain function
that has similar security properties
like collision resistance or whatever we
want and if we have that then there are
like generic transformations that
transform this fixed length hash
function to a full hash function that
has arbitrary length input and this is
what's called a domain extension scheme
so here a full hash function H is
computed by this domain extension scheme
D which is some algorithm that uses a
fixed length hash function f as a
subroutine to evaluate h on some input X
and produce Y at the output and of
course we want to do this in a way such
that the full hash function eight
inherits any security properties that
that F might have Nick sorry one more
thing I wanted to say is basically that
that all practical hash functions that
we are using are constructed that way
like using a domain extension scheme so
here's an example for offered on a
domain extension scheme which is called
the sponge construction and it's used in
in the shaft sha-3 hash function
standard so here for an input X we split
it up into chunks of are bits each and
if you know if X doesn't is not a
multiple of our we pad it in some
particular way and now we evaluate the
hash function as follows using you know
using blackbox access to a fixed length
function f that has input size equals
output size so first of all we append a
number of zeros to X 1 the first chunk
and evaluate F on it now we XOR the
second chunk into the first part of the
output of F and then we apply F again
and now we keep going like this until we
have kind of processed all of our chunks
here there K of them and then we apply F
at least once more actually there
one can generalize this by applying by
generating and longer output but here
I've just taken the simplest case we
have evaluate F once more to generate
the actual output Y okay so after we
have kind of an overview of what a hash
function is how its constructed at least
like kind of on the on a high level and
and about the security properties let me
go into a bit more detail
we're in cryptography hash functions are
used so in this in the nest competition
for for Standardization of force control
cryptographic schemes there are
basically two kinds of skills that are
standardized signatures and key
encapsulation mechanisms which are
precursors for for public key encryption
and on the signature signature side
first of all all signature schemes use
this hash and sign paradigm this is
basically the only efficient thing to do
at least that we know of I think by the
way if anybody is more of an expert than
I am on any of the topics that I talk
about then I'm happy to be corrected and
so some digital signature schemes that
are part take part in the NIST
competition use this generic
transformation that I already mentioned
the so-called Fiat ramier transformation
and I we'll talk about this more later
right and then there's another subset
which is our so-called hash based
signatures and here basically the hash
function security is the only assumption
that goes into the construction of these
digital signature schemes also four key
encapsulation there's kind of different
degrees of involvement of a hash
function in these schemes so first of
all as far as I understand all hash
sorry all key encapsulation mechanisms
use a hash based key derivation function
so basically the final key is is hashed
again to avert a certain class of
attacks and some key encapsulation
mechanisms actually I'm not exactly sure
whether whether all that partake in the
mist well I see okay so basically it
seemed like all key encapsulation
mechanisms that are submitted to the
next competition it's not Muslim as I
wrote on the slide use the so called
Fujisaki or Kemal so transformation or
at least one of its variants which is a
generic transformation that upgrades the
security of of public key encryption
schemes to achieve the strong notion of
chosen ciphertext security okay so after
we have basically an overview over what
a hash function is and how it is used
let's have a look at the kind of at the
meta strategies of how to attack hash
functions so as we have seen if we want
to contract a cryptographic scheme what
we have to do is we have to come up with
a fixed-length hash function then we
have to apply the main extension scheme
and the resulting full hash function we
can use in a cryptographic scheme so
this kind of gives three you know
classes of attacks depending on which
level of detail of the construction of
the hash function we look at first of
all what we could do is we could you
know apply the nuts and bolts of the
construction of fixed length hash
function so you know there's like some
operations happening some nonlinear
operations that that make this this this
fixed length hash function intractable
we think but you know one can one can
try to attack it
another option is we could regard the
fixed length hash function as kind of a
black box that has all the security
properties we like but then you know we
could try to attack the domain extension
scheme so it's supposed to ensure that
the hash function H inherits all the
important properties of F but maybe it
doesn't so maybe we can we can you know
find an attack that that
exploit some insufficiency there and
finally we could just regard the the
hash function as something monolithic
just you know a function that has all
the security properties we like and we
could try to attack the way it is used
in cryptographic schemes so now I would
like to give an example for for all of
these or one or more examples for each
of them so first of all if you want to
attack the the low level structure
that's actually something I know very
little about but I was pointed to a
paper that that appeared just a couple
of days ago on the on ePrint which
improves classical differential
cryptanalysis on hash functions using
quantum algorithms so this is something
but it's something one could one could
read if if one was interested in in
figuring themselves basically on the
second level where we try to attack the
domain extension scheme there for
example in a paper by by Chris and Andy
and and some others do it is actually
about provable security of the sponge
construction there's also an attack
presented on on the sponge construction
and it it doesn't use anything about the
structure of of the you know of the
fixed length function f here but what it
does is it it finds a collision of the
whole hash function H by essentially
just finding a collision of of this
low-level function of the of the fixed
length function you can see this right
like the the standard quantum collision
finding algorithm has complexity two to
the two to the N over 3 if you search in
an n-bit a search room you know if the
function has an N bit codomain and here
there's there's number 2 to the C over 3
so C is exactly the size of the second
part of the output of F
so it's enough to find a collision of of
the second part of the output of f2 to
find a collision of the whole domain
extension scheme now finally if we want
to attack the full therefore the use of
this hash function as a monolithic
object used in in a cryptographic scheme
that's that's basically what the rest of
this talk will will be about so
basically the two examples that I want
to talk a talk about are these two
generic transformations that are that
are used a lot in impulse quantum crypto
so to do that I would like to first you
know explain the two transformations the
future mere transformation it takes a
certain kind of interactive proof system
and makes it non interactive so this
certain kind is so-called sigma protocol
which works as follows so we have
approver and a verifier and the prover
wants to prove some statement X the
truth of some some statement X the fair
verifier doesn't believe it and ask the
prover to prove it and how do they do it
they do it by running an interactive
protocol and the interactive active
protocol works like this at a high level
so the prover sends some message a to
the verifier now the verifier chooses a
random challenge see from some challenge
set independently of a and finally the
prover sent some response R and now if
everything went right if this is a good
Sigma protocol now the verifier should
be convinced of the truth of the
statement X and note that in print
engine in general right maybe it's it's
difficult to determine whether X is true
or not and maybe the verifier is you
know has doesn't have sufficient
computational power to do that but maybe
the prover knows it and and he can prove
it to the verifier without the verifier
being able to compute the solution
himself this property that the prover
chooses
the challenge at random is called public
coin and basically the security property
that we want or one of the security
properties which which basically let the
verifier conclude the truth of X is
called soundness now the future sameer
transformation as I said takes such a
protocol and makes it non interactive so
how that how does this work basically
the idea is if we work in the random
Oracle model let's imagine we work in
the random Oracle model for a second
so now we have this random function so
when at whatever input we we provided
with maps it Maps it to an independently
uniformly random output so what we can
do now is we can replace the challenge C
that was previously sampled by the
verifier by the random Oracle or the
hash function evaluated at the
concatenation of the statement X and the
first message a so why does this work
why does why is this is a meaningful
transformation so basically you can see
that what happens is that the hash
function replaces the interaction as an
enforcer of you know time order so the
the reason why we need to do this in an
interactive way is that we need to force
the prover to first commit to sending
some message a and afterwards we provide
him with the random challenge as though
if we are the verifier and now basically
the intractability of
age shouldn't insure that the only way
for the prover to come up with a pair a
and C that is consistent with the hash
function is by first choosing a and then
in putting it into the hash function and
obtaining C okay so we will talk about
the security of this later let me first
show how it can be used to construct
digital signature schemes so now
basically what we have is we have a very
similar structure we still have this non
interactive proof system obtained from
the future mere transformation but now
we are using a particular class of
statements where it's efficient to
sample pairs of statements and witnesses
so the witness is something where where
you can that basically lets you
efficiently verify that the statement
access to and now what happens is that
that that's basically what is used as a
public secret key pair so there's this
witness and that's the secret key that
lets the prover determine the truth of
of of the statement X and therefore also
prove it and the only thing that we have
to do now is in this hash function that
generates the challenge C we have to
include the message in the input so that
kind of a indivisibly connect the
message with the truth with the proof
itself of the statement and if there's a
number of additional properties that
that proof system has then basically the
verify can be sure that whoever
generated this proof actually had the
witness aka the secret key and intended
to send a message M that's how a
signature mere interacted
non-interactive proof system can be used
to construct it as those signature
scheme okay before talking about attacks
let's let me quickly also introduce the
other transformation which is called
Fujisaki O'Connor or kimoto
transformation so here we are we have a
weakly secure public key encryption
scheme and we want to upgrade its
security so a generic public encryption
scheme it has it takes them as input and
message m and some random tape R for a
random string R and it generates the
ciphertext C using the public key and
the decryption function of course takes
the ciphertext C in as an input and
recovers the message M now if this if
this you know this scheme is not
sufficiently secure for our standard
if it doesn't have chosen ciphertext
security we can apply this for the sake
of an emotional transformation so what
it does is it D randomizes the
encryption scheme first and after that
it adds an additional hashing and
authentication step to ensure this
chosen ciphertext security is usual to
decrease the utility of of a decryption
Oracle so how does this work so first of
all we use a hash function again
basically thinking about it as a random
function to replace the randomness input
of the encryption function so now as you
can see this is a deterministic
encryption scheme right because the
random input is determined
deterministically from the message m and
now that we have a deterministic scheme
we can add this authentication step
which works as follows so now we're
talking about the key encapsulation
scheme that's why these algorithms have
different names and let's look at this D
capsulation functionality first so what
does it do it takes the ciphertext and
then it it decrypts it to obtain M but
then it actually Rhian
using the correct randomness that the
encryption should have used and if it if
it doesn't get you back the Sacre Dex C
then it basically refuses to work but if
if this wasn't honestly generated due to
mystically generate the cipher text then
it outputs the hash of M using a
different hash function and now that
we're talking about Innoko and key
encapsulation mechanism the the
encapsulation function also outputs this
hash so now we have a functionality that
basically in you know generates a shared
secret key if everything goes right okay
so now that we know these two
transformations let look let us look at
at attacks on these transformations so
first of all about the future mere
transformation so if we work in the
quantum random Oracle model then there
are security groups proofs since
recently so we were able to prove that
if we have a dishonest poober so
remember that is that we are talking
about this proof system so in this non
interactive version that is results from
the Fiat transformation if we have a
dishonest poober
that makes q queries to the random
oracle the quantum queries to the random
oracle that that models our hash
function then such an attacker cannot
prove a wrong statement with more with
higher probability then a factor of
order Q squared larger then the optimal
success probability in the interactive
version so basically in the parent
scheme that's that's much simpler or if
much more intuitively secure okay so
this is this is a nice theorem and
independently
this was also pruned by Lu inch and E
with the with the looser bound so one
natural question is of course can we
find a matching attack that that shows
that basically we can we cannot do
better that this is the best that the
best we can have and this turns out to
be true and to understand this attack we
need to talk about zero knowledge so
such a sigma protocol we have seen this
before right it it can have a certain
property which is called zero knowledge
and to understand this we first have to
observe that that the prover sends these
matches messages a and R and supposedly
he is using some and information to
generate them that that the verifier
doesn't have so in some sense the
verifier learned something from this
transcript right at least he learns the
fact that X is true and the idea of zero
knowledge is now that this is exactly
what he can learn so basically that he
cannot learn anything else but
the truth of the statement acts so
formally we need to formalize this in
some way and the way we formalize this
is by by requiring that transcripts can
be simulated
you know without additional information
except the information that access to so
a bit more formally but still informal
this can be put like this so a Sigma
protocol Sigma is honest verify your
knowledge if there exists a simulator
this would be efficient efficient
algorithm that for all true statements X
can sample transcripts fake transcripts
ACR such that these are
indistinguishable from an actual
transcript in the protocol okay so now
how can this be right we have we have
this proof system it's supposed to to be
hard maybe maybe the statements are hard
to it to prove in general but now what
happens here is that s does not have to
respect this time order of generating a
first and then receiving C and then
generating R so that's basically the
demand is that the simulator s has over
over the actual proof system but now
this is great right we have this machine
it generates valid transcripts because
the verification algorithm is kind of
something that every everybody can apply
so if they're supposed to be
indistinguishable then have they happy
to be valid these transcripts and you
know because we model the at least we
did model the the hash function as a
random Oracle with a small probability
actually this transcript will look like
the transcript from the future mere
transformation right because with some
small probability the hash of X comma a
is indeed equal to C the the output of
the simulator but that's great because
what we can do now is we can grover
search for such a transcript how does
this work so s is of course publicly
available it's a it's efficient and
randomized so let it explicitly take
this randomness in
into account so s takes as input a
statement a statement next that is to be
proved and a randomness input row and it
generates this transcript now we define
a function that depends on H and X and
it takes as input a random string role
for the simulator and it outputs one
whenever the simulator produces one of
our desirable transcripts right and it
produces a transcript such that it's
compatible with with with the hash
function and note that this function can
be computed using a single query to 2h
if it's a random Oracle and if it's a
hash function it can compute it of
course so now this leads us to this kind
of more or less straightforward cover
search strategy so if we have a sigma
protocol that has perfect honest verify
zero knowledge and a property called
special sound is on top of it and some
some ID additional properties where I'm
I'm pretty sure that they are not
strictly do the necessary if you put a
bit more work into into proving things
then there exists a quantum point a
polynomial time attacker that makes Q
queries to eight if it's if it's a
random function at least that succeeds
in breaking the theorem you
transformation off of Sigma with
probability Q squared over Q squared
times the the soundness error of Sigma
and this is essentially because this the
special soundness property it ensures
that the soundest error is indeed
[Music]
okay yeah so this this ensures that that
is that this soundness error is actually
so small that you know that actually the
grover search gives us the the required
advantage now how relevant is this
attack so signal protocols that are used
for future Musa signatures have at least
some form of one is very far as your
knowledge because that's what used what
is used to to prove chosen ciphertext
security and they also have some some
form of special soundness or a similar
property that that has a kind of a
similar effect and therefore I expect
this at least to be kind of somewhat rel
relevant in and in practice okay so now
that we that's great right we completely
figure out a fear term you know and the
answer is of course no because we worked
in the quantum random Oracle model and
so in the quantum random Oracle model I
think we figured pretty much we pretty
much figured it out I've of course
there's some some cases that that our
attack doesn't cover but it should be
fairly general but the problem is that
the random Oracle model cannot be
instantiated so this was in the classic
place already proven in in 98 by
Connecticut Reich and Halevi so there
exists a digital signature scheme that
uses the hash function if if this hash
function is modeled as a random Oracle
then this digital signature is a scheme
is secure but it's insecure whenever I
use any efficiently computable function
H
so that's of course a bit discouraging
and this this was a later generalized to
the quantum random Oracle case by funk
song and and Edward Eaton basically by
proving that the scheme the separation
schemes out also secure in the quantum
random Oracle model so even though the
quantum random Oracle gives model gives
the attacker more power it's the
separation Soul holds up this of course
points to the fact that there might be
better attacks than than the one that
that doesn't use any structural property
of of the hash function and no matter
what happens to be truth okay now let's
come back in the last five minutes or so
to the Fujisaki Okamoto transformation
so here is it again remember that we
started by randomizing the encryption
scheme by replacing the randomness by a
hash function and then we added this
authentication step by re encryption and
hashed output so let's denote these
three schemes the the initial one by PI
the intermediate one by PI Prime and the
final one by PI double prime so for
proved imposed on quantum security of
this transformation again usually the
the hash functions eight and H prime are
modeled as random Oracle's so what we
want is we want to take a scheme PI that
is in CCI secure or even weaker one way
see CPA but let's let's let's look at em
CPA as a starting point here and now for
the deterministic intermediate step we
want to prove to prove one way CPA from
using the M CPI property of Pi and
finally we want chosen ciphertext
security and CCA secure key
encapsulation for for pi PI double prime
now in this paper by by Andy and and and
others
as a tight reduction for the final step
provided actually so I didn't introduce
this transformation it's a slight
variant of of the one that I've shown
for simplicity but a weak one can modify
it a little bit and then one gets it a
tight reduction but for the first step
there's we only have a lossy reduction
and actually in in the quantum random
Oracle model proof there is a
multiplicative loss of the number of
queries that an attacker in this pipe
rhyme scheme here sorry let me go back
makes to this this hash function M H
that's used to do randomized that we
model as the random Oracle now this this
implication is tight in the classical
run so that's kind of annoying and
there's no attack known that that
explains this gap so can we apply our
vanilla approach growver probably not I
would I would say because basically what
it usually can do is it can boost an
advantage of of Q for for Q queries that
exists classically - Q squared that in
the quantum setting and we don't have
any classical advantage here now the
question is of course can we apply any
other algorithm and this is exactly the
question that that then asked on in an
email that was sent to the participants
of the program just another remark so of
course here the same caveat applies with
respect to the the quantum random Oracle
model as well let's take a little bit
more offer of a closer look at what was
the problem so right we we want to
assume that we have in what quad-core
goes wrong in the reduction so basically
we wanna assume that we have an attacker
that breaks one way the way one-wayness
of this scheme so it takes C and comes
up with a message M for a random for a
mercy that's generated from a random
message M now we want to use this
to break and cpa of this scheme here the
problem is in the NCPA game what we can
choose as attacker is this message m or
at least we can provide two two messages
and one of them is chosen at random and
encrypted but we have no control
whatsoever over the random SR and for
for these encryption schemes in general
one cannot see from the ciphertext C
which randomness R was used so now
basically the problem is that if we want
to use this attacker as a black box we
would need to provide him with a
ciphertext C together with an Oracle H
that's consistent with it so basically
with an Oracle H such that H of M is
equal to R whatever I was used to
generate the the challenge ciphertext
and this is something we can't do
because we don't know our and why is
this not a problem classically so
classically what we can do is we can
choose two random messages as challenge
and now we can run this this guy and
even though we provide him with an
inconsistent Oracle at some point it
there needs to be a query where he for
the first time queries the message m and
note that he can only choose query the
message m that corresponds to the cipher
text he received because the other one
is independently random so he doesn't
know it he doesn't know he will only
create with with negligible probability
so so this is how we can extract the
message m and basically win the NCPA
game but in the quantum setting although
it seems like for a fixed classical
ciphertext C that comes from a fixed
message M it doesn't make sense to make
superposition queries we have no way of
extracting this message M because
internal the adversary could make
superposition grave so we we just don't
know how to how to basically extract it
when we provide the adversary with an
inconsistent Oracle okay this is
basically all I wanted to say so what we
talked about is that hash functions are
used essentially everywhere in crypto so
we
need to subject them to some some
quantum cryptanalysis and there I shall
basically how there's there's this
different level levels of detail where
you can attack when looking at attacks
in of the application in cryptographic
schemes there are some open problems
especially regarding this for the sake
of commercial transformation you know
the one can only expect polynomial
advantages because they are reductions
that that it preclude anything beyond
that but this is still important at
least if we kind of take quantum script
analysis seriously in the sense that the
we expect it to be used for parameter
choice at some point then polynomial
factors are extremely important Thanks
[Applause]
the kid Direction function you mentioned
what kind of properties do I think that
usually the proofs are in the random
Oracle model so I don't know probably we
probably we don't know how to how to do
with less
[Applause]